da das letzte abschnitt der absolute
oberhammer aber das passt überhaupt
nicht
also deswegen so deswegen ich kann das
nicht beschreiben ich kenne mich mit
[Musik]
was hast du keine bomben am kopf
leute was geht herzlich willkommen bei
unseren ein video hatte geht es um
klamotten also wie viele leute was geht
ab und herzlich willkommen bei einem
neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut als
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen wir einmal
zu anfang das ist ich habe ja schon
viele videos gemacht sehr sehr viele
produktvideos auch in letzter zeit und
das ist jetzt mal ein video
da freue ich mich richtig drauf weil ich
muss eigentlich nichts machen außer
gucken und so ein bisschen
ich glaube es wird schon hart witzig und
zwar sind wir letztens auf die idee
gekommen dass wir mal ich habe mich in
letzter zeit sehr viel zeit ruhig und
alle anderen plattform wisse ja und da
gibt es jede menge fotos wo halt frauen
wirklich freizügig gekleidet mit so
dessous und so und das sieht wirklich
hammer aus und ich also auf ein
produktfoto ist wie das ist es bestehe
also das habe ich nicht bestellt ich hab
so praktisch so party auf so was genau
bei den paar sachen da muss doch noch
was zusätzlichen hinweisen das würde ich
das nicht bei mir glaube ich zumindest
wichtig ist doch zu sagen wir wollten
das eigentlich zusammen bestellen dann
hat sie gesagt bestellt das doch einfach
so dass ich es nicht weiß und das habe
ich auch gemacht ich habe insgesamt 34
sachen bestellt die sind angekommen und
die dafür vielleicht alle hintereinander
anziehen
ich war nicht einmal vor ich glaube es
wird grausam dass auch bevor du gleich
die sachen anziehst schauen wir uns
einmal das produkt an auf dem foto wie
es aus ich zeig dir das und dann darfst
du das anziehen okay okay
ja ich würde sagen wir haben gar nicht
lange lebten nach oben hier schon mal
wenn ihr bock auf weitere partner und
ich verspreche euch es wird witzig die
sachen haben alle maximal neun euro
gekostet also neun euro sondern gespannt
aber sind also sind
warnte outfits ja alles outfits also das
sind halt so endres
wollen sie es wie heißt das war von
wollen sie ist man okay gut dann würde
ich sagen will aber gar nicht lange so
stellt sich schön in die ecke und darfst
einfach dem anderen anziehen ich setze
mir jetzt schon eine spannung die ecke
und du kannst du mal in die
umkleidekabine gehen nach hinten in
meinem zimmer private wir packen wir
packen's vor der kamera in berlin
da passt es dass ich sage oder brauchst
du das nicht das wäre das einzige teil
weil ich sagen dass dies wollte also das
kannst du so nicht anziehen so weiß es
genau
nein jetzt noch nicht jetzt
jetzt schauen wir uns erst die anderen
ja man das war mein lieblingsteil also
das haben wir uns auch direkt mal kurz
am computer das sind zwei teile und zwar
haben wir einmal ein ja so ein rock 'n'
also ja ach nee das ist doch das ist
halt auch mal durchsichtig oder wünscht
sich das nicht
aber ich finde die qualität geht sogar
oder erinnert mich ein bisschen an so
dann kommen wir jetzt noch zum das ist
schon das campus war ja das schon das
letzte
ich habe nämlich auch noch im
hochzeitskleider die schnellsten
da kommt das video darf bekommt dann in
die nächste runde
herausstellt die qualität finde ich euch
noch nie
also das riecht irgendwie vorher nach
wald oder so also bei diesen sachen
kannst du ja gut bei den bock das muss
ich gleich spontan entscheiden wie wir
das nachher auch das so zeigen wie es
wird schon mal kurz auf die andere
kamera leute also das ist jetzt unsere
typischen outfit position jetzt darfst
du einmal nach hinten gehen in st das
erste teil anziehen
alles endet glaube ich ist alles die
größe und ganz wichtig ihr könnt auch
direkt in die kommentare schreiben
welches auto am besten findet und was
euer erster eindruck dazu ist also ich
bin jetzt wirklich mir extrem gespannt
so durch hat schon wir uns noch mal kurz
die produkte an das seht ihr jetzt
vorher marie sie jetzt zum ersten mal
was sie da eigentlich getragen dann
weißt du und wir haben gerade schon
direkt den ersten fehler bemerkt hier
beim ersten foto alex extra gefragt wie
man das finden sein
und ich habe das nach hinten gebunden so
dass jetzt das erste outfit hat mich
acht euro gekostet da muss sie haben
halt noch mal eine ganz andere
ich habe das hier in weinrot bestellt
und hier fällt auf dass man das nach
vorne bilden muss ich finde das ist
jetzt aber egal oder also ich würde
sagen deine figur ähnelt so der hier
oder soja und diese sitzt heute das
endresultat von diesem schönen exemplar
sehen die jetzt wir fangen mit dem
ersten ausbildet das ist dieses hier und
[Musik]
jetzt geh mal wieder ein bisschen neu
aber es ist ja jetzt gar nicht so
schlecht
also ich aber seitlich kurz also sollte
ich also ich muss sagen die hose sieht
so ein bisher aus wieso nur eine
clownsnase also das passt das findet
sich gar nicht so weit komme ja jetzt
hier und das ist immer bei mir hier so
auch sogar kleider an uns unseres hier
soweit also um ehrlich zu sein finde ich
das nicht gut ich finde das hier nicht
gut aus ihr könnt gerne schreiben was
ihr sagt aber ich finde es echt nicht
gut weil das dass das sitzt gar nichts
wenn man das jetzt mit dem original bild
vergleicht warte man das manchmal kurz
machen also ich habe das jetzt kann man
mit den originalen bildern etwas erkennt
das beschauliche war als wenn man das
jetzt mit dem originalen bild vergleicht
dann die sache scheint die frauen die
sitzen da ja die sitzen da weißt du
deswegen also für den wirklich niedrigen
preis ist es okay finde ich ok nächstes
machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt das ist das hier ich muss das in
elbe stellen das gab es nur das war auch
ein bisschen groß und ich finde war ihr
das ist ja wirklich extrem eng das heißt
wenn man zwei wenn das bei dir ist auch
so sitzen würde das war wirklich gut und
das war auch mein favorit kanada über
ein bisschen durch wohl oben als auch
unten
da wie sich aber auf jeden fall ein
richtig gutes model ausgesucht
ja die sind aber ist ihm aufgefallen
dass die monster alle vom täter gleich
sind also wie das aussah 5 bar war mein
favorit ausstellung mal zwei ich bin
gespannt was er jetzt anders
[Musik]
also ich muss aber sagen ich bin bis
jetzt wenig begeistert also ich hab mir
das viel viel viel viel viel viel viel
viel viel schlimmer vorgestellt oder das
tier sein warum nach venice ist welche
bereit zur hüfte hab leider und diese
klamotten sind für mädchen mit breitem
gemacht deswegen sieht das bei so ganz
ganz normal mädchen halt auch so locker
aus
deswegen hast du jetzt vorgestellt ist
das nicht was soll das heißen
verstehst du nicht das stimmt doch gar
nicht sagt dass es für mädchen machen
brechen dürfen ja ist es okay also was
macht ihr lasst uns wirklich gut gut
oder gut ich auch fragen so und gibst du
das auch für männer gibt es sowas auch
moment also dieses abholen heiser galt
also ich bin es immer noch richtig gut
bei 20.000 extra marin ja auch mal
irgendwas bestellen was mit medien sagen
wir bei 10.000 ok darfst du bestellen
was du willst also aber halt so was ich
bin meiner frau für mich so dass diese
bahn haben sie gefühlt und zum schluss
sie der absolute oberhammer für zwei
euro haben wir hier einmal im schwarzen
body is da reingeführt beschreibt genau
ich glaube das ist hier einfach
nachgemalt weil das sei es ja komplett
überhaupt also ich weiß ihr habt
vielleicht einfach keinen reingemacht
würden ganz anderen war ich wünsche euch
viel spaß mit dem letzten rang ab das
war auch gut warum deutsche das letzte
spiel der absolute oberhammer aber das
passt überhaupt nicht
also deswegen so deswegen ich kann das
nicht beschreiben ich kenne mich mit
aber schneider ja also ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen wie das war als ich
kein sicher dass sie toll also können so
landwirt mit werden mit sowas ja bis
dahin dass ungefähr also es wird es das
riecht das gefällt mir richtig gut dass
du kannst im zirkus mit auftreten
[Musik]
nein leute ich frag mich echt ich glaube
die flanken von körper oder ist und es
gibt ja das ist halt einfach
durchgeschnitten ich glaube das hat auch
nur 3 euro gekostet
weiterhin komme das müsste man ja soweit
hochziehen
jetzt hat man derweil dass der
schlächter stadt ist das ja noch nicht
mal fest ja leute geben ein bisschen
weiter zurück aber das konnte auf jeden
fall also so sieht es zwar sehr oft aus
aber in der falschen punkt erreicht wäre
dass der track ist wirklich so schlecht
also man trägt manchmal so was in der
halbleiterbranche recht hat also heute
schreibt er sehr gerne meine kommentare
wie fandet ihr meine auswahl welches
outfit findet ihr am besten welches nur
messen ist der zweite ich bin auf jeden
fall das zweite mit abstand die aktion
zusätzlich das hier gefällt mir auch
richtig gut high fashion das ist genau
das ist trägt man so was du gesagt das
ist ein sehr gutes beispiel dafür dass
wir immer darauf achten sollte was ihr
wirklich bestellt also kauft nicht
einfach irgendwas das meiste davon ist
quatsch meine eltern sagen kann man
kauft den besser was mit qualität worauf
wir vielleicht etwas länger sparen sei
es jetzt fast ja es war von dem video
lassen doch nach oben da beim 10.000
like a pony das auch mal umgekehrt so
für mich machen
sie haben das auch
so habe ich doch gesagt am anfang wollen
ja checkt unsere instagram akon sub sind
hier kurz eingeblendet wir sehen uns
wieder und es hat mir wirklich spaß
gemacht
ciao ciao
[Musik]